my next guest is a guy who I've gotten
over the last couple of years and he's
terrific at his job and he's always been
kind enough to call him to the show and
he's calling into the show of the night
after the NBA Draft in which by the way
his Houston Rockets were the only team
to do nothing I mean obviously something
was happening I assume but no activity
no pics acquired no pics traded no
players drafted
that's the Houston Rockets general
manager Daryl Morey how are you Daryl
happy birthday thanks brother I'm not
I'm not gonna be able to compete with
your other guest today holy cow no no no
you are what we call a newsmaker daryl
morey you are last night we had lots of
news and then did nothing first time
ever we I think its first time we've
ever not had a pick crazy what was so
what did you do last night
Daryl probably made 1 million phone
calls with our staff even and no it's
it's pretty amazing how many things you
were conned how many things get done the
number of deals you talk about versus
not I got real close to one where
basically basically if a pick it got a
certain way early in the draft we would
have gotten it and if not we wouldn't so
that was just crazy and then the second
round had a lot more demand than usual
like the picks were flying around but we
usually try to buy one but none were
bought yesterday they're all attached to
second-round picks so so we we we
weren't able to get in
all right so walk me through again the
best you can without I guess giving away
whatever story you don't want you want
to keep in-house so the top of the draft
you were interested in the pick at the
top of the draft no I was that it was in
the early 20s okay and basically it was
on the clock everything had been agreed
to and we're counting that this has
never happened to me before we were
counting down the seconds and just said
hey if if this guy goes and we don't
have a deal but otherwise we do and
usually I've had that happen a lot not
I've never have it happened where the
guy went right one picked the floor so
so anyone who's been in fantasy football
leagues knows what it feels like
so you wanted a guy and then the team
you had a deal for that guy if it fell
to the team that you had struck a deal
for but the team right before yeah total
player he wanted yeah yeah exactly
okay so you never know sometimes these
deals reconstitute later and so did this
deal that didn't take place on your part
require you to give up a player on your
current roster or future considerations
to it would have involved
he would involve the roster and drastic
so but you know and you know these
things all the time they you get close
it's just the one had never gotten this
close before so pretty pretty crazy
daryl morey rockets general manager why
do you think there was so much demand in
the second round last you know I don't
know I thought this was just a normal
draft like pretty solid players with
nothing special deep but I think other
teams saw it as deeper so I think
there's a lot of activity to trade in
there's also that probably boring to
your listeners but there's a cap reason
that a lot of teams are trying to jump
into the second round this year as well
and that the second round pick pick
contracts are cheaper than others and it
and it allows you to maneuver under the
cap a little easier sometimes well I
mean I think it's interesting to to the
viewers and listeners of the show Daryl
because there's so much conversation
being taking place about that Anthony
Davis trade but the Lakers and whether
the Lakers did the right due diligence
and figuring out when is the best time
to strike a deal will want to make it
official because of the cap space that
you can offer a free agent etc et cetera
how does that how do you keep track of
all those things yes
very complicated set of rules are gotten
pretty used to them I think I'm in my
14th to 15th years so you get you get
comfortable you also have really good
people around you like we do and most
teams too and yeah I mean the rules
actually at this point make no sense
whatsoever
and we've talked to the league office
about it and the league office wouldn't
say it as bluntly as I said it but
basically the over time the Kluge's have
been seven wrapped upon the Kluge's have
been wrapped upon the enigmas the
minutes
like the all the rules they set up made
sense in the 90s and 80s and 2000s when
they originally were put in but then as
time goes by they have to plug holes and
gaps and negotiate them with the players
union and and over time the rules really
have morphed into something that makes
almost no sense if you look at it
holistically so I'll tell you one thing
that makes very little sense for a lot
of fans and yeah I guess Daryl Morey
Rockets general manager you're a good
guy to ask about this are all the pics
there were 25 of the 60 picks last night
the picks were taken made by teams that
were not picking the player for
themselves they were taking for another
team for whom they've already made a
deal and sometimes that that that right
got transferred to another team that
makes a deal and it is so confusing yeah
it's really like my friends who want to
follow our team and why it's just it's
just impossible on the nights when you
have ticks and trades and and the
reality is it doesn't have to be that
way what the NB a needs to allow is to
have tentative deals be announced and
the NFL does that I know and there's
really no reason not to accept you might
have the occasional error where a deal
falls through and then because of that a
guy something gets announced has to be
you know backtrack but that's way less
bad than the entire universe watching
our draft not understanding what's
happening so I I think we need to relax
those rules a little bit and let teams
announce their deals like they do in the
NFL so that the telecasts people aren't
putting on the wrong hats and stuff like
that what about the idea Darrell of
maybe moving the draft to after free
agency would you be good with something
yeah now that that's an interesting
concept as well that we've we've
discussed with the league other other
sports do that you obviously know the
other sports well than anything NFL does
that so yeah no it's I think it's I
think it's totally fine I would slightly
prefer and I think to have a draft after
because a lot of a lot of the trades we
make with graphics we have to make
tentative later for free agency and and
and that creates complexities so
yeah but probably I'd probably put the
draft after you know there are
trade-offs to each that one's left clear
that that answer is less clear though
daryl morey Houston Rockets general
manager here on the Rich Eisen show you
said a couple days ago that Chris Paul
is gonna be a rocket next season do you
yeah I is that all is that a 100% you
can say that with that certainty right
now I can yeah okay what would you say
would you categorize the relationship
with James Harden
Darryl great yeah okay so there is there
any there to this there that's been all
over the place I mean I've talked about
it before but you know they're they did
have like heated discussion on the bench
in Game six but for me that happens 20
to 40 times a year and of course you're
gonna have even more heated discussions
and the most important game of our
season Game six there so I you know to
me it's much to do about nothing
honestly it's been really I'm gonna I
yeah I've had times in my career where
we deserve to get just break through the
coals and attack like you had the year
we 141 when people thought we were gonna
you know be the first seed in the last
or second seed and Hetal you know the
wheels came off and and you know I
myself in the organization deserved a
lot of criticism there and I have no
issues of that this year has been odd
like it's just been really strange like
that that people are missing the fact
that we're we're going to be the
favorites in the Loess when we come out
of this in my opinion week now all these
other teams are scrambling to keep their
solid five starters together we have our
five back plus we have mid-level if
there's a trade that makes us better
we'll do it we're gonna go in I think
with the highest win over under it's not
first second so it's been a really
really strange journey for me like I'm
out take the media heat when when we
deserve it this one sort of well I guess
part of a media conversation Darryl has
been that that the people on your roster
have been made available or at least is
the word and then and then yeah Mike I
get why I get why there's been a little
you know noise
but you know look look back to Toronto a
year ago and credit suicide just as
brilliant and did an amazing job you
know they they switch coaches to a
d-league Coach happened to be our diely
coach he was an assistant at that point
for our former champion Dooley coach
Nick nurse was amazing you know that
that was a fair amount of controversy
they traded their they traded one of
their significant players I mean there
was it was you could call it a lot of
change in turmoil last year and there
was not any anything close to the level
of noise for that and then obviously
mints I did an amazing job and they won
the title so I draw a lot of analogies
between what Toronto did last year and
what we're hoping to do this year just
fight above the noise well one of the
many reasons why I love talking to you
Daryl Daryl Morey Rockets general
manager and is is you're just so free
with a lot of thoughts that you don't
hear from a lot of general managers one
being in particular a couple years ago
you just flat-out admitted that the
Warriors that this is an arms race and
that you are trying to keep up with the
arms races the Warriors were a few years
ago beginning their ascension and being
appearing to be dynastic and they've
made five straight finals as we know so
I'm wondering if any of the concept of
your building your roster or massaging
and or trading certain players might be
changed by the fact that Durant's
potentially not returning and klay
Thompson is maybe out for next year to
I'm wondering if that has affected you
it has you know we like I said before no
surprise people were amazed I said it
but it seemed like so basic to me like
we we knew we had to Diggle and state so
in the title now that's less clear that
absolutely does change how you look at
things
there you go on the state provides maybe
one of the most unique defensive
challenges in NBA history your roster
construction literally almost demands
you you factor them in especially if you
know you're going to play them I think
there's some pretty dang good next year
but obviously you know if they have
injuries they're gonna they're gonna be
less not quite as good so
yeah it does change how you look at it
the different teams that we may face
it's going to be actually hard to figure
out the path to its it's wide open which
is exciting I think this is our time to
prove it and show we can take that last
step but it's definitely more wide open
and that does change things okay
so Paul Chris Paul's a Rockette hundred
percent well what are the what are the
what's the percentage that he and harden
do another State Farm commercial
together Darrell that's actually a great
great question is that I'm Vegas I would
think pretty high I don't know I haven't
been involved in that he didn't wreck
his kitchen so maybe that was the source
of attention you know what now we need
to we need to investigate that thanks
for the call Darryl really appreciate
the insights of it's just amazing
again the were you aware of that I know
the bucks ended up with no players same
with the Mavericks the sun's move some
people around in terms of picks Thunder
the Nuggets acquired a pick from the
heat late but other than that the
Rockets were the only team no activity
obviously no decision you're just trying
to make me feel that right no no no no
it's no outward discernible activity we
know no I know it's it's tough when you
go home to your wife and friends like
what happened yeah why were you gone 24
hours a day and didn't come home two
nights cause you got a hotel next to the
arena like nothing happened thanks to
the caldera thank you guy that's down
Laurie Rockets GM for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app